Nick Cannon is Infamous for having lots
of kids I think he has 12 kids now and I
say Infamous not because there's
anything wrong with having lots of kids
I you know as a father of six I I
wouldn't be able to claim that
but because he has them by a bunch of
different women who he isn't married to
and now his uh his penchant for creating
fatherless homes has led to
or maybe has led to this show watch the
commercial here
guys you're on a game show right now
Kevin Hart and Nick Cannon are coming to
e for the mother of all game shows
having my baby with Nick get it
yeah you're going to get some
contestants that want to have your baby
we're not kidding around
let's go who's having my baby with Nick
Cannon hosted by Kevin Hart this spring
only on Eve
who's having my so contestants competing
to see who can have Nick Cannon's baby
this is literally something out of
Idiocracy we are we're at the point now
where
people in charge of this stuff they just
they watch the movie Idiocracy and they
took it as uh they took it as a as a as
a plan you know as a
uh they they saw it not as a warning of
the future but as goals to achieve
now I have seen I've so I've seen
conflicting reporting on this and some
Outlets have reported I think variety
for example reported that um that this
is a real show they really are going to
do this
now other outlets are saying that it's
fake daily wire reports that it's fake
uh that it's some kind of skit for
something else they're doing
which maybe it is I'd like to think that
it is
but either way it's it's disgusting
either way because the whole joke right
what's the joke here the joke is that
this deadbeat Nick Cannon this scumbag
deadbeat has lots of kids that he
doesn't raise
look I'm creating fatherless homes isn't
that hilarious that isn't that so funny
and quirky
no it isn't you dirt bag
you're behaving like an animal okay
copulating with whoever is willing and
and creating lots of offspring that you
don't raise
that's what animals do
okay that's that's this is one of the
things that's supposed to separate us
from animals is that we don't do that
news to you Nick
but as as human beings
we create children and we get married
and we raise them
so it's really nothing uh really nothing
funny about it
now somebody has lots of kids and they
marry the woman that they that they uh
make the kids with and they raise the
kids
and uh we want to have a fun time with
the fact they have so many kids that's
fine again it's that's that's me
but creating a bunch of fatherless homes
not exactly funny
um but I did find this part of the daily
wire report about this
so the whole I the whole idea of like
having fun with the fact that he's
creating a bunch of fatherless kids who
are going to suffer the consequence
that's not funny this is funny though
this is the part that's I think it's not
supposed to be funny
um
so
daily wire lists the kids that uh that
this guy has
and let me just read this part
Nick Cannon shares twins Moroccan and
Monroe with ex-wife Mariah Carey Sons
golden Saigon and Rise Messiah Cannon
and daughter powerful Queen with
Brittany Bell
twins Zion
oxaliden and zillion air that's zillion
one word
h-e-i-r air zillionaire and daughter
beautiful Zeppelin with Abby De la Rosa
then also son legendary love with brie
uh TC and then daughter Onyx Ice Cole
with Lanisha Cole
those are the names that he's given
these kids
I like especially Zion moxolidan which
sounds like some kind of prescription
drug he got that from he's always
watching he's up late one night and some
one of the some commercial for an
antidepressant came on and he decided to
give that name to his kids I don't know
what this is
uh this also actually isn't really funny
on second thought because these are kids
who not only are fatherless but now
they've been given these ridiculous
names as well on top of it maybe this is
kind of the The Boy Named Sue strategy
deployed on a massive scale where you're
not going to be there to raise the kids
so you give them a ridiculous name to
try to toughen them up because you know
they're gonna get made fun of it for for
in school I don't know if that's what
he's going for but uh
that would be my theory anyway but I'll
do it for
this portion of shows and move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]